Humans have invented a variety of amazingly
cruel and unusual ways to kill or maim one
another (often for shockingly arbitrary reasons).
And, of course, wars tend to bring out the
worst in people; so it’s not surprising
that war-time executions can occasionally
be among the most bizarre and cruel.
On that note, I was recently reading the first
volume of John Masters’ autobiography, Bugles
and a Tiger, and came across one of the more
bizarre execution methods, death by drowning
a person in urine.
This method of execution was used by the Pathans
(also known as “ethnic Afghans” and “Pashtuns”).
The women of this group, particularly in the
Afridi tribe of the Pashtuns (who today primarily
reside in present-day Pakistan and Afghanistan),
would occasionally execute people this way,
as mentioned by the British John Masters who
was stationed in British India when he was
18 in 1933.
…if they [Pathans] captured any soldiers
other than Muslims, and especially if the
soldiers were Sikhs or British, they would
usually castrate and behead them.
Both these operations were frequently done
by the women.
Sometimes they would torture prisoners with
the death of a thousand cuts, pushing grass
and thorns into each wound as it was made.
Sometimes they would peg the prisoner out
and, with a stick, force his jaws so wide
open that he could not swallow, and then the
women would urinate in his open mouth (taking
turns) till he drowned.
This kind of cruelty was not confined to war,
but was as much a part of the Pathans’ normal
lives as were their sturdy independence…
If a man suspected his wife of the most minor
infidelity, he would cut her nose off…
The Pathans punished an adulterer by forcing
a thick and knobbly thorn twig down his penis.
They rewarded infringements of lesser laws
by tearing a man’s tongue out by the roots.
If that all weren’t cringe-worthy enough:
It is still customary among some tribes in
Assam (northeastern region in India)… to
punish an unfaithful woman by tying her to
a post with her legs apart over a quick-growing
kind of bamboo, and leaving her there until
the bamboo grows up into her womb and stomach
and she dies.
Bizarrely, particularly given their stance
on women and adultery, there are also a few
reports of these “death by golden shower”
executions being preceded by the women first
gang raping the condemned man before drowning
him in their urine.
Lest you go away thinking that it was just
the Pashtuns who instituted various cruel
punishments, during these various skirmishes
that Masters was involved, he gives an account
of a lot of cruelty on both sides.
For instance, in one case a wounded tribesman
(both his legs broken) was captured.
Contrary to an order given by the commanding
officer of this battalion (no prisoners),
his soldiers brought him in as a prisoner.
The officer was furious and then “ordered
the prisoner to be pegged out, face up, in
front of the quarter-guard.
There was no shade and the sun temperature
was probably about 130.
The further order was that every man who passed
should kick the prisoner in the testicles.”
The prisoner died later that evening
and his body was placed in a location where
a
British soldier had previously been flayed
alive by the Pashtuns.